all right shark
nice to meet you nice to meet you
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally so i'm from jersey you
know jersey
but um
i grew up in jersey
union city
you know i kind of moved on west new
york north bergen university jersey city
all around jersey and what was your
childhood like you had mom and dad um so
at the time when it was around like 12
my mother passed away she overdosed
in bronx and stuff
then my grandmother that i was staying
with moved to massachusetts i went to
foster care
nowhere patterson
everywhere bro in the [ __ ] world bro
eventually my dad came out of jail he
passed away i was 19. i had a job
i was working in the back of the trucks
garbage trucks you know throwing out the
trash having
killing it had my overheats bike my car
but we're doing the
what were we doing with the garbage
trucks um i was picking up the trash so
you had a job yeah i was in the back
yeah i had a job
long story short i got my ubereats bike
my electric one and then i got my car
i got my car i was worrying about too
much about my car i didn't have that
parent so for you to be responsible
and
little by little i stopped going to work
seven days straight i didn't go to work
i had to sign the paper to quit
that kind of you know upset me but no i
don't care i got my obvious bike i got
kicked out my crib
i moved on to different friends this
house stuff like that should have
happened i lost my bike you know i had a
cheap block the bike was already [ __ ]
up but
the luck i don't know what happened bro
somebody took it i didn't care because i
fixed my car
so i was chilling i don't care i don't
want to leave my car chilling
long story short some girl took the stop
sign early morning
i wasn't off no drugs or not
she took the stop sign i hit her and it
was my fault everything you know
i lost the car and then i got into like
a little
a little depression i guess you could
say you you hit a a pedestrian um no i
hit her car
she was in a car and i was in a car and
was there how bad was the damage um
it was where the car was never
not told they both told anyone hurt um
no she wasn't hurt everything was good
it's just but you lost your car uh
that's my car yeah i was really upset
how do you know um right now i'm 20. at
the time
how far did you go to school
um
i went to oh yeah i got my high school
appointment already
my high school diploma when that seemed
to graduate which is the only thing he
said
for him to be able to see you know
because he was he was on the respirator
twice and then you know he slowly he
said oh no i'm gonna get recuperate well
that wasn't gonna work out so you're
dead what happened you're down um
it was
the egg that causes these his used to
fill up he's super skinny
i didn't talk to him for a whole week
and we was going through a little
argument i just felt like i didn't like
i didn't want to talk to him and like
that was he passed away it was like
you know family slowly turn their back
on me how long ago your dad passed away
when i was 19
around april so if i'm right above
something i don't know exactly
so you're all on your own now right now
all of my own my family you know they
slowly turned their back on me i got
into some things that i should have
never been
but you know i'm just
trying to restart you know that's why i
came out here
restarting my life trying to see what's
new because the world is huge why stay
in one state when i could travel
somewhere else you know how long have
you been in new york city
um
i could say about a month already if i'm
right you're you're homeless here i'm
homeless over here i'm trying to get my
life ready
i've been
day one over here
and it was kind of a close to ride are
there drugs are part of your life
um
they are but they're not really an issue
in my right now you know more racial is
just
being
going day in and day out like night time
and daytime problems because i'm not the
only one homeless around me obviously so
there's other people that got to do
do things to survive
and you know you notice that after a
while how are you supporting yourself
um
whatever the dollar shows you know you
got to do anything bro sometimes you got
to take from stores and you know do
things that you don't want to do
you have some nice jewelry on yeah i do
have some jewelry on i have
so a funny story some guy was sleeping
on a bench
but he wasn't really sleeping he was
more or less like just
sleeping you know
my boy's like oh [ __ ] look at the bag
like all right so we want to go take it
so we go take it we walked up to him he
just stood still he already knew where
it was
he took the bag
before that
you know it was a lady she was taking
out some money out the bank
i was doing this for myself i was
already pissed off and i have no money
in my pocket
i was just going through it
you know this guy said no he gave me
some food i was like damn you couldn't
spare anything
i walked up to her i'm like man you help
me out she didn't she just ignored me
she straight just ignored me i just felt
some type of way you know she had her
money in her hand like this
like flying like this while she was
saying no money yeah
you know i feel bad you know because i'm
not a bad person you know i got a heart
that's golden armor made of steel
and it hurts but like you've got to do
things to survive you know so i came up
that day
and again
people's places and things
the people i was with i always spend the
money
and i noticed certain things that when i
have money
there's people around and you got to be
careful
you know and i'm not only saying slowly
little by little it's not like you a kid
just got up and just started walking you
gotta learn little by little you know
so
stuff like that that's happened
um
i have somebody has asked me for weed
before
oh yeah you got weed yeah oh yeah i know
somebody has weed how much 40 dollars
he went took out the money oh yeah i
wait right here
yeah i'll go get it i'll go get it
because you can't go over it you give me
the 40 dolla
some other guy the same thing he had a
freaking
a gushing face bro he was bleeding he
said awesome people dropped me
like damn i feel bad i just need some
weight bro
all right relax let's go get weed
eventually he got tired
i was like look just roll your blood i'm
gonna go get it all right damn yeah all
right shark man you know what i trust
you bro
i'm like yeah that that's that's cool
bro
he had more money on him i said no just
give me 40. i'm gonna get eight
wins on a block then come back
you know these are things that i as a
person if i had money i would not do
to another person but when you're at the
bottom
and it just comes across you it's like
damn
i don't know this person from a campaign
i'm trying so hard
to
be cool with him and everything but
sometimes that person just doesn't
connect with me and i just got to play
that part
it's survival exactly
don't get me wrong if that's my family
remember anything like that's not what
that would never happen
because i'm a loyal person if i saw you
i actually i shall love i shall because
i love you is not a word i say to
anybody
you know it's just not earned like i
love you i have love for you is a
totally different story i have love for
you i do not love you because love is a
strong word to say i love you is a
strong word to say
well i was living in new york city
different than were you
lived in new jersey i go by this little
saying you know i made this myself i
have this on my little facebook it's a
little bit more detailed but if you
don't ask you don't feast if you don't
feast you don't eat if you don't eat you
don't survive if you don't survive why
are you in the jungle because when
you're in the jungle you got to be a
monkey if you ain't no monkey don't be
in the jungle because only a strong
survive am i right because time is money
and life's a gamble
and you got to play it
you got to play it right man
remember
a king on the chessboard only moves one
space because that space
pretty much defined how he made his
kingdom am i right
but
ask me man i'm sorry bro what kind of
lessons have you learned on the streets
there's special lessons you learn here
be careful who you surround yourself
with
always be prepared
be aware
and just make sure
make sure
you keep your money
somewhere hidden
on you
on
don't leave it in a purse
a book bag
no
because
i have gotten money taken from me i had
a person
hey
i'm thinking oh yeah i got your world
relax you're gonna give me a bike i'm
about to play
i had my person uh right on my lap i sat
up on the thing i was taking off my
shoulders like yeah man look at my feet
whatever boom
it's to me took it from me
hey yo you think i'm playing with you
son look i just got you there
because
these are things you learn
when i took the a from the kid i've
learned that because i've dealt with
that i got god before that's how he did
i have one time went uptown i had i had
like about 50 hours worth of you know
drugs and stuff
boy yeah i met some guy he painted this
beautiful picture y'all love that i'm a
real ass [ __ ]
you'll give it a 50. look there's my
motel right here
this is my car he went around the car
but he never opened and what a question
i didn't believe
i really believed him but whose car is
this it's my car [ __ ] [ __ ]
he really yo he made it seem so real but
he never
opened the carts in the car because of
where someone can say i have a million
dollars in my pocket
but unless you see it
you don't
know and and it's crazy that's that's
crazy because
i came i gave him it
and he said yeah i'm gonna go around the
corner i'm gonna open the door
he never came out and i was like damn i
got god again
again because i was already multiple
times this happened yeah trust is hard
dude trust is a very strong thing
trust cause they could say they trust
you and they might do a couple things
this right right but when it comes down
to
damn bro do you have any friends
can i say i have any
i probably have friends in jersey
but to this point right now in new york
i haven't really like traveled back out
there to really
see them now the way i am
you know see what i've been through
because i don't think they know what
i've been through i haven't had a phone
in about a whole month
a whole month is this lowest point in
your life right now
i wouldn't say my lowest point because
i've been lower than this but this is my
hardest point
you know my hottest point losing both
your parents now is
you have no you have nothing to fall
back on
not even because i there was no reason i
never fall back on them
i never really lived with them
even when they were alive even when they
was alive you know they had other kids
with each other different people i was
the only one from them both yeah
but i never really fell back on them
regardless do you feel you were loved
when you were kid
was i
i was loved oh yeah hell yeah even
though they was there they showed love
here and there but there was it was on
their habits too
you know
so i understood you know my mother was
going to college she stopped doing her
drugs she went out to bronx never came
back she got she over those then
my father came out of jail he were the
person that showed me
some of the things i know today and
showed me to be a man and show me how to
construct myself even though he was
locked up in and out of jail he still
showed me so many things and like that i
could say anything i could really thank
him you know we had a time in our life
one time we did the dead dribbles drop
we go
three two one
he scared us out jumped off what um the
daredevil's dropped it's like a six
flags is a little rollercoaster go up
amusement park yeah and then you pull
the string it's like three two one it's
like 300 feet laying flat you can just
pull the string
which is awesome but
yeah man my dad showed me so many things
you know he was doing this little thing
on the side but
he speaking he saw love and little by
little you know he wasn't the best
person either you know because he's done
things that was your dad in prison for
him um
some people snitched on me then like a
little burglary and stuff
we did like five years that was i think
one of his biggest bids
so he they cut him short a little bit
then he went back in jail and it was
like i went to juvenile
and when i went to juvenile i was like
he came out he
he showed love he still came to visit me
my home passes still bring even though
he was getting worse and worse all of
his pain everything like that his
crohn's he had i don't know what i don't
know what else i know crohn's is like he
couldn't say but like like he was it was
hard for him to walk he was really
skinny
eventually he started retaining water
his foot started getting big
all types of thing and it was [ __ ] up
man
you know he was your main male role
model yeah yeah oh yeah you know wait so
he told me this when he went the second
time he went on the respirator and he
came back
you know he was in the hospital he was
like yo
i
i fell asleep
and like i was pitch black and i had a
blunt in my hand i was walking in a
straight line talking to that people i
had known
so what could have learned talking to
them little next by next the next person
coming down the line then you see my
mother which was the last person he said
and he told me he's like
man they were just talking mommy you
never told me the conversation you just
say oh just just remember we're always
gonna be looking over me regardless of
that you know i'm gonna i'm gonna get
better but when you said i'm gonna get
better i really didn't believe that
because
you're still smoking six not eating what
you have to eat you're not doing what
you're supposed to be doing even though
he's not doing no crazy drugs you can't
smoke cigarettes you're killing yourself
if i'm on my deathbed twice and i'm
telling you
you know i
i was or something but i couldn't really
step up
and like telling me i was like i don't
like you doing the style because if i
told them that it's like oh no i'm good
i got it
it's like but now as a man that i am
right now i could i could tell him i get
to like i feel
yeah and and tell him so many things
because he has so much advice so much
advice
so much advice bro
the man was so wise
so wise
one time he was in the bus some mexican
is talking to me like hey bobby
i'm like you'll stop talking i don't
want to talk to you
my dad has headphones like you'll stop
talking to me
my dad took his headphones
you know you yo stop talking to myself
the bus was like oh
no but the mexican guy calls for it
like like like stop talking i don't want
to talk to you
you know i was younger at that time i
was still learning i was still growing i
was still acting [ __ ] stupid in
school
but i learned little by little
i'm going still i'm still learning i'm
only freaking 20 years old but i have a
mind of
you know like i feel like sometimes i
have a mind i'm like a 30 or 20 or like
something more than 20 but i feel as
though but who knows there's so many
things i got to earn
so many things to explore so many things
i don't know
oh yeah what would you like to do with
your life when you get older
well to be honest i feel like i'm in
this world
i feel like they both left me in this
world to when i have kids to do what
they couldn't do for me to do my good
and i will make sure when i have my
first kid
that he will have the world like i will
stop everything
and do everything i could in my power to
give him whatever he wants
and it's going to be hard and i might
say no
because this is what my dad showed me
and what what life is going to show me
in the future because i have no kids no
girl no no no
you know
and it's all getting tired
you know i feel as though i'm going to
be freaking famous but who knows man i
feel like i'm maybe i might be
successful
who knows man what are you afraid of
what am i afraid of
that scares you the most what scares me
life is next for me
really
don't get me wrong so everybody's scared
of something everybody's scared of
someone everything
i just feel like
what is life got for me today
what am i going to get up to today
because i can have a hundred dollars in
my pocket today and get up and lose it
because i have lost money before i've
lost 40 dollars and i have hard-earned
done crazy [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
before and lost it but not just only
losing you you could spend it on wisely
like
anything could happen
you know that's why sometimes i i get up
i'm like damn bro
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen today i
might have this money today but what's
gonna happen today
what emotions do you go through you ever
get depressed yeah are you angry so
why i went through this one depression
that i really noticed now that yo i
didn't get out
of somebody's house because they let me
stay there for two weeks
it was you know they was helping me like
didn't even like help me leave anything
it was just bringing me whatever i
needed
for two weeks i didn't get out this
house and have no phone or not
you know i was doing my things whatever
but i didn't have no i got to get out i
was scared to get i don't know
i don't know what was wrong i didn't get
off the bed black clean i'm a clean
person
i mean i can't like this is a clean area
but i see somebody's house dirty i'm
like oh my god
you know but
i didn't get outside for two weeks you
know that man right now
he pretty much made me restart
everything i don't have no clothes no
nothing this is clothes that people had
gave me
shoes
i lost all my clothes
i had took it then everything you're
carrying with you in the backpack is all
you have yeah and that backpack is new
too
just like that jackie's new i just got
that jacket saying these pants today i
just got yesterday i just got today too
it's crazy my friend gave me this
jewelry and i found this jewelry on the
floor i had some gold and
white gold
on my wrist i actually i just found out
right now that that was real gold and i
sold one for five dollars and the other
one i got
some other support
and i just found out that was real i had
an iphone today
like brand new iphone they never put the
icloud i had the password hooked it up
i sold it not for money
i could have used the phone
you know i didn't have no use for that
you know i feel as though i probably
don't need i don't need a phone
sometimes i have a phone man i'm like
damn i don't really need it if it's not
free i don't have my id
no i don't have some of my things that i
need yeah are there other drugs you're
playing around with other than pot
um
oh yeah of course there's other things
that are implied i'm not gonna [ __ ]
anybody
you know but
that's not what's going on that's not
what's
the real big issue even though it is an
issue of course but the issue is how i
move sometimes
you know i don't have
that little yo yo look at that bill but
not
yo stup nah not
like
someone to be there you know someone to
really be to be there what's your
favorite memory
as a kid
huh
as a kid man
i mean not even as
not even when i was younger men to be
honest it was literally that their
travel drop that's why i said it yeah
that was one of them the time with your
dad why
we was going up he was both playing flat
and stuff he was going up he's like yo
i'm scared as [ __ ] man you know when she
said three to one brother not pull it
quick let's just
she said three to one
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he's over grabbing
me and she's like
he was lit man does he swing back and
forth
i've done crazy [ __ ] with that you know
we have went into hotels
he has paid for girls we have trained
girls we have loud times bro with your
dad well yeah that was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
this is my [ __ ] man
i've pimped out girls had two girl best
friends
pimped him out i had
crazy because i was pimping i was
hustling i was doing that drug at the
time too
i would come into the room take my
shower and she would come in the
bathroom and
put it like what she wasn't getting
ah you get tired after a while you know
like yeah whatever yeah i got it and
then i'll go in the back come on
why because i was the [ __ ] what happened
that they
got robbed by the people that i started
with why because they was hating and i
was like damn where you only [ __ ]
came with seven dollars come on bro i
bless you now i put 220s in my
[ __ ] i looked at them
i came out the bathroom you know what
stupid [ __ ] i do left my wallet on top
of the [ __ ]
um the toilet thing i'm not the toilet
to see the the top of the
the toilet thing
instantly i noticed but it was already
too late i came in the bathroom [ __ ] my
water
they were smoking they kept smoking i'm
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you smoking my
[ __ ] i called my boy in the morning now
i'm not letting nobody get through we
pretty much stripped him butt ass [ __ ]
didn't i have nothing but i knew he had
it in his [ __ ] ass
he stuffed it up his ass wonder why
because money kept falling and then when
he ran out the [ __ ] motel and i had a
[ __ ] knife in
was about to stop i didn't do it because
i took too long but
i don't want to go to jail for stabbing
my you know
came out of the motel the [ __ ] money
still falling out it's around the corner
[ __ ] outta here
i had about 300 something dollars and
like
a good
80 more that i could have made
you know so it was like damn i still had
money on me i had to stash the miles i
was like damn
you know i had a child around me and
said because i was just i was just
[ __ ] and when they [ __ ] knocked on
the door i'm like come on bro so they
was already blowing my [ __ ] they came
twice
so they got me man
um there's some motel stories i have met
some guy that had the crystal math
you know he had a build on his book bag
you know i went i was like yo i'm just
smoking the bathroom
we became friends whatever he's like
he'll bring some girls ah yeah he banged
some girls
he was gonna do things with him he's
like yo go to the store for me i'm like
ah yo that's just farts out
uh
i took his car keys he had a uh srt 2010
if i'm right here the two door he had
like a little skull on and [ __ ]
oh my god the time of my life
and it was on a highway that suddenly i
was
chilling bro
i went to the store and came back
they was pretty much getting them here
in the night he was wow and whatever
he's naked butt ass snake these girls
was like yo what the [ __ ]
they left i'm still thinking you know i
get this car now because like what the
[ __ ]
long story short i couldn't get his car
he said
fighting i still had his car keys tipped
off i tried stealing my um his car with
my boys from jersey and that one is sour
and then you wanna eat the [ __ ] oh my
god you know what he did he took out the
[ __ ] batter you turned it off so i'm
over here oh [ __ ] my boy's trying to
distract he didn't distract him for [ __ ]
though
you know because
the people i know now if i would not now
but like
they're not
tougher with it you know so it was like
damn really [ __ ] up not moving
you know these [ __ ]
long story show make we have a car
we actually made up after a couple days
later you know he said some rumors and
[ __ ] i see him
we made up he was cool again he never
let me drop the car again
but he took me to see his wife his wife
was short like about like five three
five two beat the photo you know when i
told him like daniel let's do a
threesome
yeah
whatever but that was the last time i
seen shane he was cool people though
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
you're 20 years
again
keep your eyes open
be aware just be aware man
you know sometimes
i don't know if you notice that before
you see me or anything i look on the
floor sometimes it's not no crackhead
vibes or anything not because i have
found a hundred dollars before
at crazy store i walked past the guy i
asked him for some money he gave me a
dollar
i turned around
some white kid just goes and gives his
hand out and this is how this is crazy
get his hand out he gives me 100 bills
old school hundred dollar bill
wow that is [ __ ] crazy i'm telling
hold on
oh my god oh wait aren't you that person
oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
you know now i'm playing oh yeah
[ __ ] this is and this is added on a
story because what a coincidence life
does this to me right oh yeah i got you
here just i had some weight in my book
bag give me some weight and like
it's the fire oh how can i get i call
you when i have fire
[ __ ]
you know me
whenever i got it off how did i get the
weed in the jar i had met a girl
which i still believe that's my crush i
don't know why i still see her around
here but i haven't got her number
because she never answered
but
i met her in her dad girls weed
so she had gave me some weight in a jar
and a book bag a little pink colorful
big bag and she just gave me some food
and stuff you know she blessed my dear
then that happened
it was like boom boom what the [ __ ]
crazy and then that same
morning when i only had one dollar on me
and that money was [ __ ]
over i found out there's not a bill
after a guy
does crystal meth and homeless was
following me i'm like yo stop [ __ ]
[ __ ] mentioning around the corner
well they get like a yellow pole thing
where they i don't know like it's like
half full
i'm out of it rolled up
oh
thank god
crazy a couple days ago i just found
something it was two days ago i found
something i was on the floor
i just found money right now new york
city i just want money right now that's
crazy bro
let me show you right now i just found a
couple dollars right now
right before i met you
right before you met me man i just found
a couple hours out this is a funny
smoking whatever i see it far away
there's a guy that's working like the
transit guy
and then some other guys coming across
the street
i run it
give me that [ __ ] out of it here's my
money that's not your money [ __ ] i had
that money [ __ ] out of it mine i found
it i had left it before
but oh yeah
i feel bad but i really do feel bad but
i'm like damn bro
i seen it
the trans guy was trying to get close
but he was being scary and like he was
going to try to step on it i know what
he was going to do and like play it off
you know everybody has done that before
but now in the street outside we're in
the jungle
and if you if you're in the jungle you
got to be a monkey what's the most
what's the most important thing to know
as a hustler
as a hustler
never act
too
tough
don't be too tough
don't be tough
don't get me wrong what the [ __ ]
nah don't be don't show it so much
don't be calm cool collective
be quiet
watch
see how he moves you might be like
you know
thanks
all right that's fine sure thank you so
much for sharing your story man hey
thank you man i hope you guys have a
good day though
shark out
it was awesome
you